jetzt geht es gleich los heute ist der
tag jetzt müssen wir nur noch eine
einwilligungserklärung unterschreiben
[Musik]
warte soll ich mich wirklich impfen
lassen das thema impfen wird schließlich
heiß diskutiert wobei es zumindest
gefühlt nur zwei antworten auf diese
frage gibt einmal die position natürlich
sollst du dich impfen jeder der diese
frage auch nur stellt ist ein
verschwörungstheoretiker oder die
gegenposition natürlich nicht die wollen
uns alle vergiften ein klassisches
schwarz weiß denken dass zumindest mir
nicht ausgereicht hat obwohl ich
impfungen allgemein als große
errungenschaft ansehe immerhin wurden so
bereits dutzende krankheiten quasi
ausgerottet dieses video wird
unterstützt von blink ist das argument
für eine kur ohne impfung ist ja
folgendes die wahrscheinlichkeit sich
mit krone anzustecken und daran zu
sterben ist geringer als die
wahrscheinlichkeit an einer impfung zu
sterben und dass das der fall ist
scheint an und für sich auch recht
schnell bestätigt zu sein tatsächlich
ist laut robert koch institut
mittlerweile jeder ein tausendstel
deutsche an kroner verstorben 93.000
fällen auf circa 380 millionen einwohner
sind das 0,1 prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung bei rund 9 millionen
erst impfungen mit astrazeneca gab es 21
verstorbene also eine sterberate von
0,00 0 24 prozent wodurch das risiko
sich mit krone anzustecken und daran zu
sterben
scheinbar 458 mal größer ist als durch
die besagte impfung aber nun hängt das
ja sehr stark mit dem alter zusammen was
man auch sehr gut an dieser grafik
erkennen aus den offiziellen daten des
rk ii geht also hervor und das hat mich
komplett überrascht das ist in meiner
altersgruppe deutschlandweit bisher in
anführungsstrichen nur 78 todesfälle
gabe von circa 10 millionen 20 bis 29
jährigen starben also nicht 0 11 prozent
sondern 00 008 was zwar immer noch ein
stück gefährlicher ist als die 0,0002
vier von der astrazeneca impfung aber
ganz so eindeutig ist das dann eben doch
nicht in sondern vergleich müsste man
natürlich erst noch viele andere
faktoren mit einfließen lassen wie zum
beispiel langzeitfolgen von krone und
impfungen die nicht zum tod geführt
haben und deswegen auch nicht in diesen
statistiken kommt das ist mit der
aktuellen datenlage aber ziemlich
schwierig ohne dabei grob ungenau zu
werden für mich als nicht mediziner aber
ich will auch gar kein vortrag übrigen
welche details halten sondern euch nur
im rahmen dieser dokumentation über
meine impfung hier etwas an meinem
entscheidungsprozess teilhaben
und eine frage die dabei auch aufkam ist
wie kann man mit so kurzen testphase
bereits ausschließen dass es keine
langzeitfolgen gibt vielleicht habt ihr
ja schon mal an das medikament kontakten
aus den 50ern gehört welches er zu
extrem entwicklungsstörungen bei
neugeborenen geführt hat und spätestens
da ist meine kompetenz als
nichtmediziner natürlich komplett am
ende es gibt eine menge plausible
argumente wie zum beispiel das in den
letzten 70 jahren seit den fünfzigern
eine menge besser geworden bist du der
medizin und im jahr
ja das macht sinn zudem funktionieren
impfungen scheinbar auch gänzlich anders
als andere medikamente und es sollen bei
impfungen historisch gesehen quasi alle
langzeitschäden bereits in den ersten
zwei monaten aufgetaucht sein weswegen
die recht kurze testphase ausreicht es
gab auch noch nie so viele fördergelder
wie bykow wird noch nie so große
testgruppen und es gab auch noch nie so
viel bereitschaft bei den behörden sich
mit ihrer normalen langsamen bürokratie
ein bisschen zu beeilen an das klingt
für mich persönlich auch alles total
vernünftig aber das sind teilweise
sachen nehme ich als nichtexperte nicht
selber überprüfen kann weswegen ich da
zum teil auch ehrlich gesagt einfach
darauf vertrauen muss dass das so stimmt
und deswegen finde ich schon wichtig
dass menschen auch über dieses thema
aufbringen können ohne direkt als schwul
abgestempelt zu werden weil wenn wir
solche ehrlichen bedenken im
öffentlichen raum nicht zulassen dann
werden normale menschen die verunsichert
sind einfach in den schatten gedrängt
und damit in die arme von solchen
menschen
letztendlich entscheide ich mich also
für eine impfung weil ich davon
überzeugt bin dass es für uns als
gesellschaft das beste ist wenn es
möglichst viele geimpfte gibt und weil
ich darin vertraut dass die moderne
medizin in den letzten 70 jahren
deutlich sicherer geworden ist und uns
die pharmaindustrie zwar finanziell
ausnehmen aber nicht umbringen will mit
einer impfbereitschaft von 86 prozent
die sich entweder auf jeden fall oder
zumindest wahrscheinlich impfen lassen
wollen sehen dass die meisten wohl
ähnlich unseren impftermin haben sophie
und ich mitte mai übrigens quasi sofort
bekommen als sowie unseren hausarzt
angerufen hat dieses glück hatte bisher
natürlich nicht jeder aber da es bei
einigen aus unserem umfeld geklappt hat
haben wir es einfach ausprobiert und so
bekommen wir heute unsere spritze beim
arzt war es dann etwas chaotisch zuerst
anstehen niemand wusste so recht was man
tun muss dann noch mal ein dokument
ausfüllen wieder anstehen warten im
wartezimmer wo ich diese skurrile bild
gesehen habe und dann ging es auch los
mit dem impfstoff johnson and johnson
film durfte ich leider nicht aber fotos
machen voller aufregung habe ich dann
aber leider nicht ganz getroffen mit der
handykamera weswegen man nur die hand
der eltern sieht
und zack ein hübsches pflaster so wir
sind jetzt geimpft und fühlst du dich
ein bisschen schwierig aber es kann auch
in meinen hunger liegen
ich glaube also ich finde ich gar nicht
anders ich habe mich aber auch jetzt
geradezu entschieden aber keine
nebenwirkungen zu haben ich weiß nicht
ob das funktionieren wird ich hätte ich
ja eigentlich fragen können ob man
gerade in der allergie hochphase ist
gerade und dann vielleicht
nebenwirkungen habs nur weil man ist ja
sowieso dann das immunsystem ist ja
schon mit anderen sachen beschäftigt ja
mein arm tut ein bisschen weh
also ich hab mein ich noch mal deutlich
weiter drüber gekriegt die impfung an
sich hat sich ruth s angefühlt aber das
ist beantworten finde ich so das ist hat
ja eigentlich jeder andere ich
tatsächlich was mit mir bisschen
angenehmer haben hingeschaut und nadine
adeligen so rein und ich habe richtig
gespürt wie die flüssigkeit durch man
durchläuft das war wichtig dass wir den
druck sicherheit ja es waren druck und
es war kalt und ich habe auch gemerkt
wie seit durchfließt wirklich ja nicht
mehr so druckvoll ich hab so fließt
spüren also nicht wissen was hier so ein
bisschen ein bisschen bestimmt ich
wollte auch eigentlich jetzt hier eine
aufnahme zeigen aber die wollte ich dass
ich film ja gesagt ich kann ein foto
machen da habe ich aber nicht richtig
getroffen als es geht jetzt noch ihre
hand hier
naja schade aber ihr trainer ist hatte
beweist aber also eine stunde nach
impfungen so ungefähr
auch zwei stunden später immer noch gar
nichts 14 stunden nach der impfung wir
jetzt hier
naja also jetzt tatsächlich müssten
besser aber mir ging ich glaube so ab 4
uhr 5 uhr liest er so richtig wer so
richtig schön kopfschmerzen bekommen ich
habe ich gefühlt dass ich so eine
richtig fette grippe aber was haben ein
bisschen die erkältungssymptome gefehlt
also ich habe irgendwie keine kraft in
den händen gehabt also jetzt wieder
aufgestanden sind wie alles angefühlt so
im rücken hat total weh getan meint cup
hat richtig wehgetan also ich war echt
so also ich hatte echt das gefühl ich
werde jetzt so richtig fett krank aber
jetzt geht's wieder
aber jetzt geht es ja ich hab es erst
gar nicht gemerkt so ein bisschen
nackenschmerzen ein bisschen
kopfschmerzen aber die habe ich sowieso
eigentlich jeden tag und ich den zweiten
tag darum würde ich nicht auf dem 57 ich
glaube aber dass wir morgen da deutlich
schlauer sind
weil wenn es morgen richtig hättet ihr
könnt sein dass es daran lag und wenn es
morgen hat nicht hätte dass man einfach
irgendwas ja ich bin mega schlapp aber
ich glaube ich habe wenig geschlafen
herauszufinden ob unsere beschwerden nun
wirklich nebenwirkungen der impfung sind
oder ob es sich entweder nur ein placebo
handelt oder einfach um ganz normale
beschwerden die bei uns ohnehin recht
regelmäßig auftreten ist gar nicht so
einfach in der impfstoff studie zur
astrazeneca gaben nämlich ganze 39
prozent an kopfschmerzen bekommen zu
haben obwohl sie aus der kontrollgruppe
sind und gar keinen wirkstoff bekommen
haben sondern nur placebo mit wirkstoff
waren es übrigens 53 prozent als ich
dann gestern ins bett fiel weich dann
komplett zerstört zumindest gefühlt lag
das schon an der impfung wenn ich mich
schnell bewegt habe ich manchmal etwas
kopfschmerzen und mein arm zieht auch
noch wohlig stück wenn ich ein hoch aber
ansonsten als wäre nichts gewesen
sophie hingegen die ist noch ko also
weiter im plus war eine spritze in
deinen armen
danach ging's mir so leid es mir wieder
gut finden merkt richtig merkt bei mir
richtig dass ich mich seitdem bisschen
sicherer fühlen also einfach ein
bisschen mit beruhigter und einfach das
gefühl habe das irgendwie wir so bald
wird alles anders wird so und so
bisschen hoffnung zu machen unsere seit
einer woche dann schon gerät ein tag
vergangen sagt also nebenwirkung spring
go gibt es schöne tabelle kopfschmerzen
übelkeit
ja okay ich nicht ermüdung da schmerzen
an der injektionsstelle ja ließen
husten ausschlag auch nicht combo sind
auch nicht rückenschmerzen hatte ich
also ich habe immer noch übel
rückenschmerzen ich will eigentlich
immer selten auf die impfschäden weil
ich halt ständig irgendwelche sachen
haben zu kopfschmerzen müdigkeit aber
ich habe jetzt echt ein mal seit sechs
tagen über die rückenschmerzen und zwar
so wie ich sie doch nicht hatte deswegen
ja ich denke das ist davonkommen könnte
er wie kriege ich mal fünf stück
zusammen nicht mal ein dingo hatte ich
50 prozent importe heute bei boeing
deutschland echt also zumindest in nrw
ja für uns natürlich jetzt so für andere
leute ist anders ist es auch nicht mehr
repräsentativ echtholz wieder machen und
mehr gibt es dazu nicht zu sagen ich hab
da muss jeder einfach seine eigene
entscheidung treffen etwas machen will
ja nicht jacobi 19 trifft vor allem
unsere älteren mitbürger aber das trifft
natürlich für fast jede krankheit zuerst
gar nicht spannend einfach aufhören zu
können wird zu dem alltag wie nah wir
bereits an diesem ziel angekommen sind
und was wir bereits heute für länger
anhalten der jugend tun können erfahrt
ihr in dem buch das ende des alterns
dessen kernaussagen er jetzt mit blink
ist in rekordzeit aussagen können links
ist seit über einem jahr sponsor mannes
kanal ist wurde vor allem bekannt für
die inhalts verdichtung von büchern auf
nur circa 15 minuten wodurch man zum
beispiel in der dauer einer schulstunde
die essenz von elenas biografie der vier
stunden arbeitswoche und champions eine
kurze geschichte der menschheit lesen
oder hören könnte und das sogar in
doppelter geschwindigkeit und hörbücher
in ganzer länge gibt es natürlich auch
ihr könnt euch jetzt einfach kostenlos
überblick jetzt.de / story in der video
beschreibung bei brink ist anmelden und
sieben tage quasi unbegrenzt das wissen
aufsaugen noch bevor ihr ein abo
abschließt wenn ihr dann merkst dass die
unzähligen bücher voller wissen aus
kategorien wie
persönlichkeitsentwicklung wissenschaft
unternehmertum und psychologie genau das
richtige für erleben sind dann erhaltet
ihr 25 prozent rabatt auf das jahres-abo
blinkt ist premium ganz oben in der wie
die beschreibung linke.de / mary und das
amt von diesem video schaut gerne bei
der sophie vorbei die macht koch videos
und abonniert organisational man das
sehen zunächst müller macht's gut
[Musik]